Just before we get started,
I do want to say I've got a brand new
channel.
It's called biographics,
longer form,
20 minutes ish.
Biographies about notable people from
history,
not just politicians at all sorts of
different folks.
Please follow the link in the
description below and check it out if
you're looking for something else to
watch.
All right,
so in the tax it is the largest fashion
distribution on the planet and it's the
most successful company in the history
of Spain.
It's got an annual turnover of
$27,000,000,000 and consequently this
company has managed to make it into the
top 60 largest companies in the world.
And if you want a buyer,
well then you better have a thick
wallet.
Get need to spend $125,
billion dollars to make the acquisition.
Company name might be unfamiliar to some
of you,
but I am sure you will recognize many of
its fashion labels.
Look inside this corporation and you'll
find such well known brands as Zara.
Massimo Dutti,
his Stradivarius show,
Zahra Parkway,
and although smaller,
you can also find lefties,
they are low cost brand,
partly flagship brands of this
corporation is definitely Zara.
I'm sure you know it's.
It's our stores open in almost every
country around the world and it is here
in Zuora where the corporation makes 60
percent of its total sales for the most
striking thing here is not just the
figures,
it's the company's evolution.
It just a few years into Texas,
turns into the world's largest textile
group with stores on the most expensive
streets in the world and it all started
as a modest Spanish
in a.
This
kind of thing might be less unusual in a
country like the USA,
but I can assure you it's ratified in
such a phenomenon in Spain.
That is why we're going to analyze
interjects today from its humble
beginnings,
through the keys to its success,
and of course,
well,
it's immense.
Profits,
origins of a giant.
No.
The
origins of insects.
We must go back to the seventies when
Spanish businessmen that Amancio Ortega
opens the first Zara store.
Now you might be wondering,
where did Ortega get the inspiration to
start out such a profitable moneymaker?
Well,
it's difficult to say,
but we do know this man has been
involved with the fashion industry from
a very young age.
When he was only 14,
he was already working as a delivery boy
for a well known shirt shop in a small
industrial city in the north of Spain.
Yup.
Times have absolutely changed.
Back then,
Spain was very different to how it is
now.
It was a much poorer country and it
wasn't unusual to find a 14 year olds in
employment,
but let's focus it on the thing.
Ortega sort was a clear business
opportunity and he seemed designed it to
make his mark on the international
market in 1988.
He opened his first store outside
Spanish,
borders in Porto in Portugal.
Soon after he crossed the Atlantic and
set foot in New York and he has been
unstoppable since then.
The UK,
Japan,
Kuwait.
Right now you can find an intersect
store in almost every large city in
capital city in the world into tanks,
brand owner of Zara and plans to open
stores in Vietnam,
New Zealand,
Paraguay of Aruba and Nicaragua.
This year,
the voice of Vietnam today into it says
more than 7,000,
300 stores across the globe.
It's made markets were Intersex,
has more shops outside Spain that in
China and Russia,
as you can imagine,
all of there's international expansion.
Well,
it's certainly had a reward or take it
to that child who saw no other choice
but to work to survive and do founded
into tax when he was almost 40.
Is today one of the wealthiest people on
Earth.
According to Forbes.
Ortega's fortune is more than
$55,000,000,000 and well there is the
billion dollar question.
Well,
how did he do it?
let's take a look at that.
Keys to success.
As you say that innovation is limited to
the realms of the high tech industry.
Well,
you probably don't know about into tax
and pay attention here because we're
going to look at how this company has
turned the entire textile industry
upside down by competing in a very
different way to rival company
for textile industry thing.
It doesn't exactly sound incredibly
groundbreaking does it as well.
This company,
they've achieved immense growth growth
which can mainly be attributed to
innovation like daring to be different.
Now let's analyze in depth some of the
keys to business success first.
Well,
we need to pay attention to the
company's brain.
Yes,
interface does have some sort of brain
and this is the operation room that the
company established in our t show.
A small town in Galicia.
Now you could be forgiven for mistaking.
This is some sort of NASA control room,
but at least for now,
no rockets or satellites have managed
from here in this room.
They control and analyze everything that
takes place across all of the companies.
Stores can real time.
You see,
even though a large part of the clothing
production takes place in countries like
Morocco,
Turkey,
Brazil,
or Bangladesh,
everything or almost everything goes
through Spain before it is sent to
stores.
For instance,
let's think about a Zara store in
Shanghai.
It would be logical for us to think that
since the clothes are made in
Bangladesh,
that they should be sent directly to
China from that.
Right?
Well,
that's not what happens at all.
They're actually taken to Spain and then
they sent back to Asia.
This might seem counterintuitive,
but it does have an explanation.
No.
Shops sell the same quantity of each
type of clothing.
The purpose of this operation is to
control how much is sold and what's kind
of thesis are sent to each of the
groups,
shops,
the model,
the color,
the size,
et.
Yeah.
Considering this data,
the stores receive pieces of clothing as
appropriate for that individual needs.
It is only logical,
for example,
that the Zara on Fifth Avenue of does
not sell the same items that the Zara's
of Miami beach or I bet key to success
is logistics,
which is closely related to the first
one,
intersect supplies its doors two or even
three times a week,
and they can deliver to any of their
stores in just 48 hours.
You can imagine what's in it for this
requires,
but with this time in the company,
it gets several things in return.
They reduce stock in storage and reduce
the storage space required in the shops.
Less dark means less money and less
storage.
Space means more space for sale.
In all of this means,
well of course that means more money.
Furthermore,
it also helps to have an updated sales
line,
and this by the way,
is the third key to into Texas success.
No more lasting collections
company.
The clothes aren't often renewed on
average every fortnight,
so dive Teesha is not selling.
It's out just like that in finishes from
the shelves and never to be seen again.
However,
if a piece of clothing is selling well,
the customer knows he won't find many
people wearing the same products because
it's production is limited to a short
period of time,
so when something is popular in itself
as well,
the company doesn't provide more of
these items.
What the designers do is they sort of
recycle the model.
The essence is kept,
but some modifications are made so they
follow the trend,
but they don't repeat it.
It all explains why every time we walk
into one of these shops,
most of what we see is different to the
products we saw the last time.
So to sum up with the operation room,
daily analysis,
logistics,
new designs,
well,
this company is starting to not sound
that traditional,
isn't it?
But I'm sure you probably want to know
more about those huge figures.
Say,
well,
let's jump into that now.
The large figures,
if there weren't three words to define
this enormous player of the fashion
industry,
these would be well growth,
growth,
and yeah,
the third word would also be growth.
Now we've discussed the main keys that
have helped to build this empire.
So now let's see what's going on within
the company and to do this,
we need to take a look at the periods
between 2006 and 2016 and only 10 years
into text has been able to multiply
their sales by three.
They've doubled the number of stores and
they've expanded to 50 new countries.
Not so bad for just 10 years.
Right?
Well,
in previous videos like the one we did
on Amazon,
we said we'd like to highlight the real
money company generates.
That is the difference between the money
that comes in and the money that goes
out the cash flow.
Well,
if we do it again for Inditex,
we can see the cash flow has multiplied
by three in the last 10 years.
If we look at the numbers,
we see how this real profit has gone
from one point 4 billion euros to 4
billion euros every year.
In other words,
Mr Ortega System,
it's certainly works and this does not
just work great for shareholders because
inditex has been an absolute employment
machine.
This company now has more than a hundred
and 60,000 workers around the world,
but that's not the end of it,
not even close because if we bear in
mind all the suppliers that inditex
works with,
that number could be in excess of a
million workers,
million people that in one way or
another have a drama because of a
company that was born in the 19
seventies in a small city in the north
of Spain,
a company that was founded by a humble
man,
a worker with ambition.
It's all variable.
I.
That is why would Tayga has become an
idol for many young Spanish school
students.
They aspire to be like him when they
grow up.
Spanish high school students want to be
like a month ago or take a in the
future.
Anyway,
now I see all.
Do you often find yourself shopping in
stores even though maybe it never heard
of it before?
I'm wants your opinion on Ortega.
Well,
please let us know in the comments
below.
Also,
do not forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday can.
Don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast
today provided the vocals in this
episode that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.